okay good morning
so today we're going to
begin our discussion of nitrogen
metabolism which is
really going to continue over the final
three lectures
in the class now nitrogen of course
is critical for life you need nitrogen
to make
rna and dna as well as protein
and so what we will see is is that
as we discuss the metabolism of amino
acids
and nucleic acids
not so much how they contribute to
protein and
rna and dna but rather how they
interface with
other pathways in metabolism to lead to
how these molecules are synthesized how
they're broken down
and what you will see as we go through
these discussions
is that understanding the metabolism of
these molecules really
is all about how organisms handle
nitrogen
now of course we've spent much of the
class
talking about how fat and sugar can be
oxidized as a way for cells to get
energy
and of course that's very important a
major role of fat and sugar is
energy transduction but of course cells
are mostly made out of protein
and so roughly 50 percent of a cell by
by mass is protein and protein therefore
is a key part of our diets and really
any animals diet
that eats other organisms so anything
that's non-photosynthetic
has to be taking in a lot of protein
because it's eating other
organisms in one way or another now
you will of course know that nucleotides
are central for genetics and the
heritability of life and so
life couldn't exist at least in
heritable form without those
and often we equate things like amino
acids and nucleic acid metabolism
nitrogen metabolism
as all about energy and weight lifting
so you know weight lifters all the
supplements that are sold to help people
get huge
all of those things usually involve
heavy loads of nitrogen so
creatine we talked about that earlier in
the course leucine is a very common
weightlifting
supplement these are all nitrogen
containing compounds and it makes sense
because if we're going to build new mass
for cells
we certainly need nitrogen to build the
protein that's what half the cells are
as well as the nucleic acids that enable
cells to
um go on and build new cells and in fact
you know roughly
50 percent as i said the mass of a cell
is
protein and another 10 is nucleic acid
so
really a large chunk of what our cells
are comes from these nitrogen containing
compounds
however maybe something you don't think
about as much is that we also
because we have to eat other organisms
consume a lot of protein in our diet
and therefore protein is particularly
different amino acids also end up being
a very important
nutrient and in fact our muscles and our
liver
are storage organs if you will
for amino acids and so our muscles are
always
getting bigger and smaller breaking down
rebuilding each other
um as uh as as we go through life
as they really participate in um in
in our in our body's metabolism
in fact you have tons of
energy built up into your muscles and
if you starve yourself stop eating you
can live off of muscle tissue for
quite a lot of time and that is really
using the amino acid breakdown from our
muscle tissue
really there is a way to to to uh
keep keep glucose in our blood high and
keep our brain
thinking right that's why we talked last
time
about the keto diet when we talked about
the keto diet remember if you're going
to do this properly and really be
ketogenic
you can't eat glucose of course but you
also
can't eat or or carbohydrates but you
also can't eat protein
and the reason is is because the liver
will turn your amino acids back into
in into glucose and that's true whether
those amino acids come from the diet or
those amino acids can come from the
breakdown
of muscle all right
so if we use amino acids
as a source of energy as a way to
support gluconeogenesis to keep our
carbohydrates available for our brain
we need a way to metabolize those amino
acids
and if we metabolize those amino acids
we also then need a way to deal with
all the excess nitrogen and so
indeed we already introduced how this
works and if you remember back when we
talked about the mal8
aspartate shuttle
what you'll recall was a way for us to
transfer electrons from the cytosol
into the mitochondria and involve this
convoluted
swaps between aspartate and oxaloacetate
and glutamate and alpha-ketoglutarate
and at the time we introduced how amino
acids are related to
alpha-keto acids okay and so i drew out
how
oxaloacetate an amino acid
is related to the alpha keto acid
sorry how the amino acid aspartate is
related to the alpha-keto acid
oxaloacetate as well as how
the amino acid glutamate is related to
the amino acid
alpha ketoglutarate okay just to
be very explicit remind you what i meant
for this and so
here is the amino acid
alanine
okay so this is the amino acid alanine
it is related to the alpha keto acid
pyruvate
and again the same relationship if you
look back in your notes when we discuss
the valid aspartate shuttle
glutamate alpha ketoglutarate aspartate
to oxaloacetate
really the keto group the alpha keto
group
is being replaced with the amino group
and it's should be clear to you
now is that if you can convert an amino
acid into an alpha keto acid
that is dispose of the nitrogen get the
ketone back
it should be very clear how you can then
oxidize pyruvate oxidize oxaloacetate
oxidize alpha ketoglutarate as a way
to get energy directly burn it in the
tca cycle
get atp nadh that way or turn it into
glucose
via gluconeogenesis however
if we're going to do this obviously
these nitrogens
have to go somewhere and if you're going
to build amino acids
those nitrogens have to come from
somewhere and that's really why
the pathways that we're going to discuss
really are about
nitrogen metabolism and how cells deal
with either the excess nitrogen from
breaking down amino acids and nucleic
acids
or how cells um obtain
that nitrogen as a way to build
these molecules
now by way of introduction we have to
discuss
also where is it then that nitrogen
for biological systems really comes from
in the first place now this is almost
never an issue for
animals and that's because we and other
animals eat
other organisms and so we eat other
organisms usually we have a problem
of dealing with too much nitrogen
however
for photosynthetic organisms how to get
nitrogen
ends up being a real problem and so
any of you who have done any gardening
knows that you need to add fertilizer to
your plants
what is fertilizer well it's primarily a
source of nitrogen
as well as as as a as a phosphorus
and really it's the nitrogen and the
fertilizer that's helping
solve the problem of where the
photosynthetic organisms are going to
get the nitrogen that they need to grow
now of course there's a lot of nitrogen
nitrogen gas in our atmosphere
all right but nitrogen gas is incredibly
inert right you use nitrogen gas as an
inert gas
to basically stop things from that are
too reactive
uh from from reacting with the air in
the lab okay
nitrogen gas is very stable molecule is
not at all useful
to biology however
if we take this nitrogen gas and we
reduce it
okay that is we add a bunch of electrons
all right what we end up with now is we
end up with
all of these
um uh reduced nitrogen groups these
these uh um amino groups that are
incredibly useful for biology all right
these come up over and over again these
are the side chains of our
amino acids they're found on all the
cofactors they're
forming the hydrogen bonds between our
different nucleosides
okay and so enzymes work
genetics happens hydrogen bonds form
because of
all of these nitrogen containing
compounds
but you need a way to get from this
nitrogen gas
down to this reduced nitrogen and that
is really so-called nitrogen
fixation
which is basically taking nitrogen gas
and reducing it to be a compound like
ammonia okay so paul's adding electrons
that ends up being one of the things
that the magic of biology that really
makes
life possible now you don't often think
about
nitrogen fixation very much so obviously
we all know that photosynthesis is
really central to what makes life happen
and we spent a lot of time talking about
photosynthesis
apart from photosynthesis which of
course takes the energy from the sun
and gives us a way to uh get reduced
carbon that
all life depends on nitrogen fixation is
a way to take nitrogen gas from the
atmosphere and turn it into ammonia
a useful form of nitrogen for life to
use
and what you may not realize is nitrogen
fixation really only occurs in a select
group of prokaryotic organisms
so these are really the
unsung heroes of life or at least the
young sun
sung heroes of metabolism it's probably
the most central topic to life that
we're not going to spend a lot of time
talking about in 705 simply because we
don't have time
um but it's basically redox chemistry to
take
nitrogen gas add electrons to it and end
up with with uh
reduced nitrogen this is very energy
intensive requires on the order of 16
atp molecules
it's covered well in various textbooks
if you're interested in reading about
this
further but i really want you to
appreciate that this
is something that really has to happen
and it's really relatively few organisms
that
allow this to happen for all other life
on the planet to be
dependent on this is really why
fertilizer ends up being the thing that
you add to your garden
right so in the wild nature would set up
symbiotic relationships with
other organisms with these nitrogen
fixing organisms in order to get the
nitrogen they can get
however we can help that process along
by giving
by giving fertilizer there's a lot of
fertilizer runoff
you know you get algae blooms that's
really because
all this nitrogen now gets dumped into
the water that ends up being rate
limiting often for photosynthetic
organisms like algae to grow
and so this ends up being a really
important topic if you're interested in
environmental science or if you're
interested in agriculture
and it's at least something i want to um
make you aware of from this introductory
course
all right
now for most organisms
we get from either our diet or from the
environment
fixed nitrogen and the two
forms of fixed nitrogen that we need to
discuss is
ammonia as well as
the conjugate base of ammonia
which is ammonium
now fertilizer is of course very rich
in ammonia and animals that eat other
organisms
get lots of nitrogen from breakdown of
proteins
and that is a source of ammonia or
ammonium ions and so photosynthetic
organisms have the problem of getting
these
animals often have the problem of how do
we get rid of this
now if you've ever cleaned with ammonia
you know that it's pretty nasty it
smells bad it's a cleaning agent
it's very toxic to lots of
organisms at high enough levels and so
animals really need strategies or all
life really cells need strategies
about their how they're going to handle
and deal
with these um uh
you know nitrogen containing compounds
either to incorporate it
or to get rid of it now i'm going to
spend a lot of time today talking about
how animals
who take in a lot of uh eat other
organisms take in a lot of nitrogen
have to deal with the nitrogen excess
and it turns out that
you can deal with the ammonia that's
generated from the breakdown of your
amino acids
in lots of different ways and basically
there is no one solution that life uses
that's universal for how you deal with
the excess nitrogen
really different strategies have been
involved incorporating
the metabolism of amino acids and
nucleic acids
that fit the lifestyle of different
creatures
and so fish
and other aquatic
life really deals with nitrogen
because they can just excrete
ammonia directly
they live in the ocean lots of
excess space into the ocean just take
the ammonia
send it off into the ocean the large
volume of water in the ocean
means dealing with um ammonia
is not such a big problem literally
pissing into the ocean
um to get rid of their excess
ammonia their nitrogen waste
now terrestrial animals
i'll just say terrestrial creatures
have a different problem to deal with
and that is
they can't tolerate the high
concentrations of ammonia that would be
necessary to just release it into the
environment so they need
another solution and of course our
solution
is to excrete our excess nitrogen
as urea
so that's urea this is why we make urine
and it's really our solution to
eliminate
excess nitrogen is to concentrate that
nitrogen rather than excreting its
pneumonia
as ammonia but to make urea put it into
our urine
and eliminate it um um
through through uh urination now
not all animals make urea okay
things like reptiles and birds which
turns out
making urea requires access to lots of
water
okay reptiles don't always have access
to lots of water they live in dry
climates
birds don't want to have to carry around
all the extra water weight of dealing
with urea so instead of urea
it turns out that they excrete their
nitrogen as
uric acid so what's uric acid
okay so this here is uric acid
so uric acid is basically appearing
so should look very similar to the
adenine and guanine
rings that you saw earlier in the class
and so
they basically generate uric acid
which allows them to excrete more
nitrogen
with less water and so bird poop birds
don't urinate
the bird poop that you get that slurry
of material
is basically a mixture of solid waste
and uric acid
and that's how birds eliminate their
waste all in one
all in one go as a way to
save some water as they deal with their
excess nitrogen
all right the fact that different
terrestrial
creatures some like us make urea some
make uric acid
really deals with shows that urea you
will see today is from amino acid
metabolism uric acid is of course
from a purine from period metabolism
we'll talk about that in the last
lecture of the course
they really illustrate how the
metabolism of amino acids and nucleic
acids is really about
the metabolism of of nitrogen
and how these pathways are really set up
in a way
that allows exchange of ammonia
with amino acids
as well as with
nucleic acids
as the nitrogen can really flow between
all of these
different biological molecules and along
the way well this allows a way to
excrete nitrogen it also obviously
involves ways to incorporate it and is
really
the pathway cells use to both make and
break down
um um these compounds
all right now as humans
we of course eat a diet that's high in
protein
higher in protein now the current fat is
to
eat high protein diets that's the latest
trend that's healthy
and this involves lots of nitrogen
excess
and so we have to as humans urinate
several times a day because we need to
excrete
lots of nitrogen now that's really
our amount of
urea out okay so that urea out
really in a healthy person is balanced
with the nitrogen in
from the diet
okay makes sense if
we are not growing okay and we eat a
certain amount of protein
if we eat more protein
that means we need to excrete
more nitrogen if we eat less protein
and we need to excrete
less nitrogen okay and so
the nitrogen in and out should be
balanced
now the reality is is that not all of
our nitrogen is excreted
as urea some of it ends up
in the stool as other compounds and so
for a healthy person nitrogen in
is greater than nitrogen
out in the urine
okay urea okay nitrogen in is really
greater than nitrogen
out and this is what is referred to
medically
as positive nitrogen balance
so if i collect all of your urine for 24
hours and take keep track of all the
food that you eat
and i measure all the nitrogen in the
urine and all the nitrogen and the foods
you eat
there's going to be more taken in that i
measure in the urine
that's positive nitrogen balance and
that what is what is standard
healthy for most
most humans now if there's positive
nitrogen balance
it means you can also have negative
nitrogen balance
which really means that the amount of
nitrogen
in is less than the amount of nitrogen
out that is you are losing more nitrogen
in the urine
than you're taking in medically this is
a very
bad thing okay when does this occur will
occur as if
during periods of starvation makes sense
if you're not eating any food you still
need to
get energy from somewhere you'll
metabolize your glycogen you'll
metabolize your fat
but you'll also catabolize the amino
acids in your muscle
those amino acids will generate excess
nitrogen more nitrogen out
than you've taken in the diet
this also occurs during some
illnesses all right famously
cancer aids
sepsis all of these really horrible
conditions that
some people uh can be very life
threatening
many of these lead to a phenomena
known as cachexia so what's cachexia
you waste away lose all of your lean
body mass
this is also basically a state of
negative nitrogen balance and
why this is is uh you know really a
a current topic that lots of people are
trying to figure out
but it's really a case where you are
breaking down more
of your muscle protein more amino acids
and losing that nitrogen than you're
taking in
and treatment of the underlying
condition is really required for this to
get
better all right now
it turns out i can experimentally cause
negative nitrogen balance in an animal
if i remove certain amino acids
from your diet um why
is that well it's because prokaryotes
plants
yeast lots of
organisms many organisms can make
all 20 of the amino acids
that are required to build protein but
it turns out that
animals including humans
cannot
make all 20 amino acids
it's a quirk of our physiology
um but it turns out some of the 20 amino
acids that are needed to build protein
are essential that is they have to come
from external sources
so remember there's lots of vitamins out
there that we can't make we have to get
those from our diet there's essential
lipids we talked about that
um last time again have to get those
from our diet
and some of the amino acids that we need
to live
also have to come from an external
source and in the 1950s
um experiments actually done on humans
on medical students
actually found that if you take these
essential amino acids out of the diet
what happens is is that you can shift
those medical students
into a state of negative nitrogen
balance and that's because
they're unable to synthesize protein
you're always synthesizing and breaking
breaking down protein
if you don't have the essential amino
acids to re-synthesize your protein
you now break down more protein than you
synthesize and you end up with
negative nitrogen balance
so what are these essential amino acids
well i post them here on this
picture and so here's the essential
amino acid they have to be obtained from
nutrition
here's the non-essential amino acid
these can be
obtained from the outside or but we also
have the pathways
in order to make them
and so if you count these up here oops
if you count these up you will see that
there are nine essential amino acids
and 11 non-essential amino acids
it turns out that two of the
non-essential amino acids
require essential amino acids to make so
they're sort of conditionally essential
and so i think it's really
you know from the trivia standpoint i
guess
the answer is that there's nine
essential amino acids
all right and they are i'll use the one
letter abbreviation so there's lysine
histidine isoleucine
leucine valine
threonine tryptophan
phenylalanine and methionine
now there's two other ones if you have
enough phenylalanine
we can synthesize tyrosine and if you
have enough methionine
we can synthesize cysteine but it turns
out that
tyrosine and cysteine because they
require phenylalanine and methionine
for all intents and purposes are also
essential so there's really
11 of the 20 amino acids
come from
our diet either directly or
indirectly in the case of tyrosine and
cysteine
now of course our diets involve lots of
proteins we eat other animals and so
rarely is it an issue that we need these
which is probably how evolution was able
to lose the ability to make them
because we take in lots of amino acids
all the time anyway
and these are amino acids that are
primarily
important only for for making proteins
but this also really illustrates that
proteins are a large reservoir of the
nitrogen we take in
and we just take it in pre-made already
as
these um as as these amino acids
even though we can synthesize the
remaining
nine all right now
of the remaining nine amino acids these
are the ones that we can synthesize
these are really
largely ones about how we move nitrogen
around
through biological systems we'll see
that as we go through the rest of the
um the the lectures on the pathways
involving amino acid metabolism
and where i want to start with this
is how we're going to deal with ammonia
which is really exchanged
in and out of
the biological molecules
mostly via
two of the remaining amino acids and
those two
are glutamate and glutamine
so just to remind you because this is
important
e is the one letter abbreviation for
glutamate
q is the one letter abbreviation for
glutamine
okay and glutamate and glutamine are
really central
to exchanging ammonia in and out of
molecules
just to remind you what these look like
okay so this is
the alpha-keto acid alpha-ketoglutarate
ketone alpha to the carboxylic acid
alpha-keto acid
alpha-ketoglutarate okay so remember it
differs
from the amino acid
glutamate so exchange that alpha keto
group for
the amino group now i have glutamate and
glutamine
is rather than carboxylic acid
on the side chain
you add this second nitrogen group
and so what you will see as we go
through the lectures that glutamate is
really the major glutamate alpha
ketoglutarate is really the major
nitrogen donor and acceptor to get
nitrogen in and out of other amino acids
and in the last lecture you'll see that
glutamine is an important
nitrogen donor this
nitrogen on the side chain ends up being
important for
getting nitrogen into into
nucleic acids now a really key enzyme
to getting these nitrogen
in and out is the one that catalyzes
this step
right here this is catalyzed by an
enzyme called
glutamate
dehydrogenase
and glutamate dehydrogenase really
carries out
the following reaction
okay there's alpha-ketoglutarate
so this can pick up an ammonia molecule
okay so get this intermediate
and now if we have two electrons here
as a hydride ion
which of course we're donating two
electrons that's why it's a
dehydrogenase
involves nicotinamide cofactor
so these can come from either nadph
or nadh generating
nad plus or nadp plus
and so reduce this molecule
oxidized nadh or nadph
n80 plus or nadp
and you get
the amino acid glutamate
and so here's a reaction catalyzed by
glutamate dehydrogenase
that can convert the alpha-keto acid
alpha-ketoglutarate
into the amino acid glutamate
this reaction which effectively
is ammonia
plus alpha-ketoglutarate
plus nadh or nadph
can reversibly generate
glutamate plus nad
plus or nadp plus plus
water okay
so this reaction again
glutamate
dehydrogenase
very reversible reaction can use
either nadh or nadph
or nadplus or nadp plus okay either
cofactor works
and it's a key reaction to interconvert
the alpha keto acid alpha ketoglutarate
with the amino acid glutamate and get
ammonia in and out of the
amino acid pool all right so i mentioned
glutamine
is the other major nitrogen
carrier and so how is this made
well you can make it so if you start
with
glutamate and you phosphorylate
that glutamate with atp
okay so that
okay so that's now a phospho
um acid on the side chain of glutamate
lose the inorganic phosphate and now we
end up with
glutamine okay
glutamine all right
this is carried out by an enzyme called
glutamine
synthase and it's basically
another way to pick up ammonia
this process can be reversed so we can
take
glutamine so i'm not going to draw out
the whole molecule
just draw here the side chain
okay so this here would be the side
chain of glutamine
can just use water
to remove the ammonia
and regenerate glutamate carried out by
an enzyme called
glutaminase
okay so glutamate to glutamine
glutamine to glutamate glutamine
synthase
glutamines notice just like any
other reaction or pathway we talked
about
one direction is favorable the other
direction is not
so this direction requires energy input
for it to work
atp is used in glutamine synthase
glutaminase doesn't require atp because
it's
favorable makes sense with all the other
stuff we talked about
and so as animals the way our tissues
deal with nitrogen is that if we
catabolize an amino acid in our tissue
we end up generating ammonia that
ammonia
ends up either in glutamate
okay via the glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction
or it involves up in glutamine
and then we carry that nitrogen
as glutamate or glutamine
in our blood it gets transported to our
liver and our kidneys
and our liver and kidney handle that
excess nitrogen
by in our case turning it into urea
other organisms
might turn it into something else in
specialized tissues where it can then be
excreted all right and again
it also ends up being that glutamate if
we're going to make amino acids
ends up being a good source of nitrogen
and glutamine if we're going to make
nucleic acids
end up being a good source of nitrogen
and so for catabolizing amino acids for
energy
we can release ammonia via the glutamate
dehydrogenase reaction moving in this
direction
or we can incorporate ammonia by it
running
in the opposite direction okay
and so what you will see then is that
the synthesis and breakdown now focusing
on amino acids
is really going to involve exchanging
the nitrogen between alpha keto acids
and amino acids and glutamine and
glutamate
as we described for the malate aspartate
shuttle
okay so let's just show an example of
that so this is what
was involved in the malate aspartate
shuttle
okay so here's oxaloacetate
okay so alpha
alpha ketone to the acid so alpha keto
acid
this here is
the amino acid aspartate
remember in the malate aspartate shuttle
we basically exchanged the amino group
and aspartate
to be glutamate and the alpha-keto acid
oxaloacetate for alpha ketoglutarate
okay so alph-keto acid amino acid
alpha-keto acid amino acid balanced on
both sides
and nature can basically use this system
to now get nitrogen in and out of
systems okay
so take an amino acid alanine
it's related to the alpha keto acid
pyruvate
if you can exchange that
amino group onto alpha-ketoglutarate
okay
that will generate glutamate
can use that
glutamate transfer the amino
group onto oxaloacetate that can
generate
aspartate and so really here you have a
system
where you can use transfer of these
amino acids
between alpha-ketoglutarate and
glutamate and really
any alpha i'm sorry any
amino acid
and any alpha
keto acid okay
and so if we're going to catabolize
an amino acid say alanine give the
nitrogen to alpha-ketoglutarate now it
ends up on glutamate
that glutamate can go off in the blood
it can be used elsewhere
to synthesize aspartate from
oxaloacetate
or some other amino acid
from some other alpha keto acid
or it can just stay on glutamate
go here to the glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction and generate
ammonia and so for catabolism of amino
acids
the first step involves transferring the
nitrogen
to alpha-ketoglutarate and that
generates
glutamate as well as the alpha-keto acid
which can then
be metabolized if we're going to make an
amino acid
we can start with the alpha-keto acid
and transfer the nitrogen
from glutamate and that's a way then to
make the amino acid
and so glutamate dehydrogenase lets you
get ammonia in and out of the system
and then this basically transferring
of nitrogen between alpha keto acids
and amino acids involving glutamate
and alpha-ketoglutarate now allows you
to move
um
nitrogen around the system and so
that's basically in a nutshell how you
synthesize and break down
many amino acids although of course
there are some
exceptions and so glutamine
we just described it's
the glutamine synthase and the
glutaminase reaction
obviously that's how you synthesize and
break down glutamine relative to
glutamate
um okay
asparagine is
like glutamine okay remember
asparagine also it's aspartate with an
amino
group on the side chain all right just
like glutamine and so
its metabolism is similar to to uh
to glutamine arginine
okay arginine is a special amino acid
with
three nitrogen molecules we'll discuss
that at length in a little bit
proline if you look up the structure of
proline
what you'll find is that it's glutamate
that's been
cyclized and reduced and so proline is
also a little bit different you make
glutamate
cyclize it and reduce it that's how you
get proline
and then glycine it turns out is
generated from serine
and we'll discuss that at length in the
next lecture
but for the other most of the other
amino acids
reactions really involve interconversion
between
the alpha keto acid and the amino acid
and glutamine glutamate
via a series of reactions referred to as
transamination
okay and so transamination
is really these reactions that allow
this swapping of nitrogen
between amino acids and alpha-keto acids
and alpha-ketoglutarate
and glutamate some of these are very
famous
if you you know many of you want to go
to medical school
you're gonna do liver function tests
where you measure
levels of alt and ast these are the
liver function enzymes okay or the
transaminases
all right they're basically the
transaminases that
catalyze the exchange in the case of alt
between alanine pyruvate and
glutamate okay
ast is the transaminase that
catalyzes the exchange between aspartate
oxaloacetate
and glutamine alpha-ketoglutarate all
right
very active highly reversible enzymes
very abundant in the liver the liver is
important to get
nitrogen in and out of across different
amino acids
high levels in the liver cells so when
the liver is damaged they leak out and
they measure them in the blood and
that's a sign of liver damage
okay and so again
just to drive this point home
so you have alpha-ketoglutarate
ketoglutarate can be converted to
glutamate
this is the glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction
so it involves a redox step with nadh or
nadph
okay that allows you to interconvert
the
ammonia basically
take nitrogen in and out of the system
as ammonia
and then once it's in the system
now you can do transamination
to move the nitrogen between glutamate
alpha-ketoglutarate
with any other alpha-keto
acid and amino
acid
all right and so if you're going to
catabolize amino acids
you go in that direction
right and you're a fish you go this
direction
release it as ammonia or you can come in
this direction
and that is anabolism that allows you to
build amino acids all right
okay so these transamination reactions
then become very
important and we need to discuss how
they work
so transamination itself requires a
cofactor
this cofactor is called
pyridoxal phosphate
okay it's derived from a vitamin
like many cofactors in this case it's
vitamin
b6 also referred to as
pyridoxine okay
vitamin b6 vitamin b6
looks like this
okay so that's paradoxine that's vitamin
b6
turns out we eat vitamin b6 and the
active form
in the cell is
is this molecule where um
this alcohol has been
oxidized to the aldehyde and this
cofactor is referred to as pyridoxal
phosphate
and abbreviated plp
for pyridoxal phosphate
all right
so
all right now let's
go over how peridoxal phosphate
allows these transamination reactions to
occur so let's start off here with just
some
generic amino acid
okay and so the transaminase
has
okay so here's pyridoxal phosphate i'm
not going to draw the whole molecule
just
skeleton of the pyridoxal phosphate
so it reacts with the amino acid
okay so that's that middle part here
of the molecule
okay generate the shift base
you
just draw the top part here
foreign
okay so here now we generate the alpha
keto
acid
and
and this alternative
version of pyridoxal phosphate
called pyridoxamine
which is also abbreviated p
m p okay
and so basically i've exchanged
the amino acid
transferring the nitrogen onto plp
to make pmp and generating
the alpha keto acid
that pmp
can now react with some other
alpha keto acid
okay so here's our
pmp and basically if i just reverse
all those exact same steps that i just
did
foreign
so i'll do for sake of
brevity here i'll do two steps and one
okay so i broke this up here into two
different steps before
but to save me some drawing i'm just
gonna
do one here
and all i did is just run the same
mechanism in the opposite direction
and now i've taken my alf keto acid
got the nitrogen from pmp regenerated
now
a new amino acid as well as
not going to draw it all out but
regenerated
paradoxical phosphate and so
pyridoxal phosphate ends up being this
really useful cofactor that enables
this transamination reaction that is
this interconversion
between an amino acid an alpha keto acid
and another amino acid or
alpha keto acid and so
pyridoxal phosphate is a cofactor that's
also useful for
other amino acid containing reactions
basically enables this sort of chemistry
that
enables nitrogen to
you know this sort of chemistry to
facilitate reactions with amino acids
we will see in the next lecture that we
will use pyridoxal phosphate in a
slightly different
way to convert serine to glycine plus a
one carbon unit that we can use for
something else
i don't have time to go into them um
in this introductory course but
periodoxyl phosphate is also involved in
other amino acid reactions so
last time we discussed ethanolamine and
remember ethanolamine is an alcohol
that's found in phospholipids
phosphatidyl ethanolamine
serine is used to generate ethanolamine
and pyridoxal phosphate
basically enables decarboxylation of
serine to generate
ethanolamine serine can also be turned
into pyruvate and ammonia it's a
alternative way to generate ammonia that
also involves
paradoxical phosphate and if you're
interested you can look up
these reactions and their mechanisms and
see how
pyridoxal phosphate is repurposed for
those
reactions all right but for today's
purposes this is what pyridoxal
phosphate is
this is how it allows transamination and
so now it should be very clear
how it is that fish can eat a bunch of
protein containing food
and excrete nitrogen into the ocean
all right and that is they can take
whatever some amino acid all right
they can do a pyradoxyl phosphate
containing
transamination reaction and
generate the alpha keto acid with the
nitrogen
going on to alpha-ketoglutarate to
generate generate
glutamate this alpha keto acid
can now be oxidized
that's favorable that can be used to
generate atp
and allow the fish to get the energy it
needs
to swim that glutamate
can now basically carry out the
glutamate dehydrogenase reaction
generating ammonia regenerating alpha
ketoglutarate
to accept the next nitrogen to allow
oxidation
of the carbon backbone and the amino
acid
and the ammonia can float off into the
ocean
um where it doesn't hurt anybody and be
fertilizer for some
algae all right and so
there is a way to take catabolism of
amino acids get energy
and excrete the nitrogen as ammonia
basically involving
transamination
which requires pyridoxal phosphate
and glutamate
dehydrogenase
all right now
turns out tadpoles do the same thing
because they live in water
but when a tadpole becomes a frog or if
you're a mammal
you don't do this anymore because now
you don't have
infinite water to excrete into and so
instead as i said earlier we're going to
generate
urea as a way to excrete nitrogen
and of course i mentioned earlier i'm
not going to draw it again but birds and
reptiles
because you'll see making urea requires
a lot of water
you can save even that water by making
uric acid appearing instead
now how you make purines will be
discussed in the last lecture you'll see
how you make uric acid there
but for now i want to discuss how
we generate urea
as a way an alternative way to
deal with amino acid catabolism and
excrete nitrogen turns out that
as we discuss how you
synthesize urea also discusses how we're
going to make and break down
arginine one of those um exception amino
acids
and you'll see why arginine and urea
are really tied um to to metabolism in
the way they are
and so let me just remind you
what arginine looks like
foreign
okay so this here is the
amino acid arginine
all right i'm going to redraw
part of this side chain here in a
different color
okay and i did it that way because i
want to show you
how this is related to urea
so if i take water
um
taking off that end of the arginine
molecule
generates urea
all right and so
what we're left with after we do that is
this
this other amino acid which is
not found in protein but is found in
metabolism
and it is an amino acid called
ornithine and so
basically if you break down
arginine into ornithine you generate
urea and so it should be clear that if i
can now create a cycle
where i take ornithine pick up a couple
nitrogens
and regenerate arginine now i have a way
to
basically produce urea
because then i can cycle arginine to
ornithine
make urea pick up two more nitrogens
regenerate
arginine and that's a way to generate
um urea now this series of
reactions occurs via
a cycle called the urea cycle
okay and the urea cycle was also
described by our old friend
hans krebs so remember hans krebs
described the tca cycle
turns out the urea cycle was described
by hans krebs before the tca cycle
and is really the first cycle um
described
and so part of the inspiration for the
tca cycle came because hans crabs
already had cycles on the brain
from describing the urea cycle now it is
a common misconception that all cells do
the urea cycle that is absolutely not
true
lots of cells carry out reactions that
involve the urea cycle because it's also
involved in arginine metabolism all
right but
the urea cycle as we're going to
describe it is really at least in
us selective for our livers and our
kidneys
because this is really the series of
reactions that we run
to net generate urea which ends up in
our urine okay and so remember it would
be nitrogen transported to the kidneys
or the liver via glutamate or glutamine
and then
and end up ultimately
entering this urea cycle to generate
urea
now this involves reactions that will
occur
in multiple compartments in the cell and
so most of it happens in the cytosol but
there's one reaction that occurs in the
mitochondria
and so a general overview is as follows
okay so
i just showed you how you can start from
the amino acid
arginine and generate
the non-proteinogenic amino acid
ornithine
all right
this will involve production of urea
all right that reaction
occurs in the cytosol but the next
reaction
which is ornithine picking up
a co2 as well as ornithine
picking up an ammonia to generate
another
non-proteinogenic amino acid called
citrulline this reaction
occurs in the mitochondria
and then that citrulline will pick up
another nitrogen
it shows you how it does this in a
minute to make a molecule called
arginosuccinate
and then that argenosuccinate will be
turned back in
to arnold into arginine and so
a four-step cycle this reaction
ornithine to citrulline happening in the
mitochondria
and then regenerating the arginine from
citrulline
in two steps happening in the cytosol
and the arginine back to ornithine
in the cytosol to generate urea
all right now let's go through
um the details of how this works and
we're going to start here in the
mitochondria
at this ornithine to citrulline
reaction so it turns out the first
part of this is generating a molecule
referred to as carbomole phosphate
i'll write that out in a second and so
this comes from co2 which of course
is in equilibrium and cells with
bicarbonate okay
okay so there's bicarbonate
just like we saw when we did
carboxylation reactions
if i phosphorylate the
bicarbonate with atp
this molecule here then would react with
biotin and that was a way i did
carboxylation reactions well it turns
out
that
rather than react with the nitrogen on
biotin i can also react
with ammonia
that generates
this carbamic acid intermediate
which can then be
phosphorylated with adp
again to generate this molecule
which is called carbomole
phosphate okay so carbomoyl
phosphate turns out this whole step
two atps taking co2 and ammonia and
generating carbon wheel phosphate
is carried out by a single enzyme
this phosphate will then react with
an ornithine molecule
okay so here's ornithine
okay
and that will generate
this molecule which is the amino acid
citrulline ornithine and citrulline
being the two
major amino acids not found in protein
all right now the citrulline
then in the cytosol can
undergo a reaction with atp and it's
easier to see if i rearrange
this part here of the side chain of
citrulline so i'm just here going to
draw the side chain
okay so it turns out this will
react with
atp okay so i'm just going to draw
atp here in a
this stylized way
that's going to
release pyrophosphate which can be
of course pulled forward by cleaving the
pyrophosphate into
two two
inorganic phosphate molecules
do
and so now you have citrulline
with an amp
on it and that can
react with an
aspartate the amino acid
aspartate
so this is the amino acid aspartate
losing the amp
to generate
this intermediate
this intermediate which is called argino
succinate so arginosuccinate why is it
called
that because this is a succinate
molecule
here and this part here is an
arginine molecule and now
what can happen next oh by the way this
reaction here from uh basically
adding citrulline to arginosuccinate
is carried out by one of my favorite
enzyme names it's called arginosuccinate
synthase
abbreviated ass so the
enzyme is the ass
enzyme ass arginosuccinate synthase
to turn citrulline into arginosuccinate
once you have arginosuccinate you can
now
carry out that reaction which will
generate two things
from the purple half here you will now
end up
with
this molecule
which is fumarate
from the tca cycle okay
as well as i have regenerated
one of the most tedious amino acids to
draw
which is arginine
so here we have our amino acid arginine
okay and so that fumarate
now needs to be of course turned back
into
aspartate you know how to do that i can
take fumarate
turn it into malate that's adding water
that's a tca cycle
then malate oxaloacetate that's
nad to nadh and then oxaloacetate can be
transaminated
into aspartate and you can basically see
how i can run that urea cycle as a way
to
excrete nitrogen
one from carbonyl phosphate
one from aspartate to generate um
urea and so this
complete cycle is actually a few cycles
put together
sometimes referred to as krebs bicycle
or krebs tricycle and i'll just
draw it out here so if you start with
argino
succinate here in the middle
okay that argeno succinate
will generate fumarate
and arginine
okay arginine
into ornithine
will allow generation of urea
ornithine can be turned into
citrulline picking up a
carbomole phosphate
which of course is
from co2 plus ammonia
that citrulline
and aspartate come together to give you
argenosuccinate
and then that fumarate can
run by the tca
cycle to generate malate
okay so that's water
malate can be used to
generate oxaloacetate
so that is of course
okay that oxaloacetate can be used
to generate aspartate that's a
transamination
reaction so the transamination reaction
so of course glutamate to
alpha-ketoglutarate
and then glutamate to
alpha-ketoglutarate
this is the um
okay the glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction
can bring the nitrogen in
and so this here complete cycle
which you'll see is actually balanced
with respect to both electrons because
of the
glutamate dehydrogenase reaction and the
malate oxaloacetate direction
as well as all the nitrogen really
allows you to take
nitrogen as ammonia put it in the system
as aspartate
use that to combine with citrulline to
make arginosuccinate go to arginine
make urea with the other nitrogens
coming from carbon oil phosphate
to generate the the citrulline
and so the ammonia that's brought to the
liver in the kidneys
via glutamate or glutamine
can then be incorporated into aspartate
and carbonyl phosphate
and ultimately excreted as ammonia
you can see that there's lots of atp
that's required here
you need two atp here to generate
carbonyl phosphate and you need another
2
atp here
at the argino succinate synthase step
to generate argino succinate
and you also need co2 but the net effect
is that you generate
urea okay i know that
the urea cycle is complicated i will
start out next time
running through another review of it
just to make sure you have it
clear thank you